- [Mark] All right. Damien.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Damien. Where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Damien] I'm from
Greece. Athens, Greece.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- [Damien] Yes.
My dad's American, my mom's Greek.
My dad came to Greece, met a woman,
stayed out there for a long time.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- My childhood was, it
was normal, you know.
A typical childhood of
anyone from Greece, you know.
Not much to do out there,
like not like in LA, you know.
So, it was just pretty boring.
We never played video games and all that,
more outside time.
- [Mark] No traumatic childhood events?
- Well, yes actually. When
I was younger, my dad,
you know I was like a snobby
kid and you know about my dad.
A couple of times actually.
And him being the head of the household
and like it was really
a confusing situation.
Because my mom didn't know what to do.
So it, it went on for a couple of years
and then you know finally,
you know,
we just stuffed him
and we went to live with my
mom's brother for a long time.
And it was, wasn't working out there.
And I had a opportunity
to come to America.
Well, pretty much that happened,
it was for a long time this
is been going on, you know.
Me, I'm not, I'm not
getting my into that stuff,
but like, like it was
just weird, it's weird.
I really can't explain it,
but I thought it was a normal,
anyway, I thought it was okay to do.
I didn't really, I didn't
feel comfortable doing it,
but he was my father
and I didn't want him,
I don't know, I just, I
just went along with it,
you know and pretty much
we separated from my dad.
And yeah, and then pretty much,
some guy, I met a guy online and he,
he said he was a modeling person, you know
and so I, you know,
so I talked to my mom about it
he says he would pay, he wanted
me to take photos of myself
he said he would pay for a
plane ticket out to America
to pursue this modeling career, you know.
And I didn't really have
anything going on in Greece
you know, and it being
like a third world country,
not third world, but it being where it is,
there's not really opportunity there, so
I came to America. I was you
know, by myself, you know.
When I was about, this was
like 20, when I was like 22.
And I came out here and, you know, and
it wasn't what I thought it was, it wasn't
it was a 'modeling'
thing but it was, it was,
ended up finding out it
was a gay porn, you know.
This gentleman tricked
me. Because I told him
my situation, I told him I didn't have
any family coming with me.
I'm doing this by myself, you know.
And pretty much I came
out there and he told me,
like well, you gotta do
this or else you know,
you're gonna be homeless, you
won't have anywhere to go,
you won't have any money. And I don't,
I don't know this place at all. You know?
So I ended up doing, I ended up, you know,
living with this gentleman
and doing little jobs
for him here and there.
You know? Of gay porn. And
anyways, he used crystal,
I found out a couple of
months down the line.
And he told me that if I
use it it will help me,
I'll be more motivated to do
these videos and these movies.
And so I did. And it
helped. It helped, you know.
You know. In ways I didn't
like it, but in all it helped.
You know. And after a while
I wasn't getting paid the
proper money, you know.
I ended up finding out that he lost some,
he ended up doing bad himself, you know.
He lost some money and he was doing bad
and he was lying to me about payments
and he was telling me that
since he was living with me
and paying for my rent and everything
that he should be paying me less.
Anyways, that didn't work out.
So I ended up coming down here.
I mean not coming down here, I'm sorry.
While we were, well while
I was doing the gay porn,
I met a lot of people, obviously,
through Julian and that, and
a lot of them did crystal
and a lot of them were
drug addicts, actually.
And when I left this shit old man,
because I didn't like what was going on
I ended up hanging out with these people
and living with these people.
And that didn't last long.
And a lot of them moved
out here and pretty much
you know, a guy showed me out here
and says, you can just get
a tent and post up out here
until you get your life together.
And that's what happened pretty much.
I came out here and,
and I've been in kind of
I've been stealing a lot
to, to get my clothes
and so all this shit,
all this stuff I'm wearing is stolen.
And honestly, you know.
And it's just, you know,
Its' just, it's just been bad and you know
I've been trying to
find other jobs out here
and stuff. And it hasn't been working out.
And I even went to a
couple of people that I met
and they said they had some jobs.
It, but it involves porn
of, you know gay porn
and I've done a couple of those stuff.
But it's not what I want to do, you know.
And that's pretty much where
I'm at right now, you know.
- [Mark] So now you're
living on the skid row?
- Yeah. I live in a tent
right here on 5th and Towne.
I live in, I'm in an eight
man tent with my lady,
right there.
And yeah.
- [Mark] So you're not gay?
- I'm not gay, but I'm having
to do these certain things
to get, you know, to kind of
get by, for the most part.
- [Mark] Are you still doing it?
- I haven't done it in about two months.
You know? I've been, I've
been doing other means of
of getting money, you know.
That I'm not proud of, but
it's not that, you know.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So I'm out here, I'm
also using heroin now.
I fell into heroin use, being out here.
You know, I have Hep-C. You know.
And, and living, yeah. It's just been bad.
You know out here it's
just, it's bad you know.
It's you got people robbing
you constantly left and right
You've got a lot of gangs around here.
You know.
And me being white and black, you know,
like you know, you know
it's, it's weird for me,
you know, I get treated
like a little weird.
Me having dreads and stuff,
but that's pretty much it.
And a lot, if some people
found out that I was
about my videos and stuff, you know,
and it's giving me a little
hard time out in too,
a very hard time.
So it's been, it's been
difficult, you know.
It's been really difficult
and my lady too and you know.
Because she didn't know
about it for the longest time
until she found out, you know.
And that's pretty much it, you know.
Me, I live on 5th and Towne.
I've been out here for about
been out here for about,
going on two years now I
think, or a year and a half.
You know.
And it's just, you know,
it's not, it's not,
I don't know what to do right
now in my life, you know.
- [Mark] Yeah. I'm sure this
is not what you had in mind
when you were coming to America.
- No, no. It was completely,
it was completely,
I haven't even told my
family back at home.
They think I'm, they think
I'm, everything is, you know.
I've been sending them
pictures on Google, you know
of what I would like
my apartment to be like
and stuff, you know.
So they don't know what's going on.
I don't know how to tell them that.
And you know, and yeah, so...
I haven't talked to them
in a while too, actually.
You know. I don't want to burden them or
with that stuff, so, you know.
And I got my lady with me
and she has a kid herself.
And you know and well
I don't know, I just,
you know, so I'm out here, living out here
just trying to find another
way, another way to live.
Another way of moving on up,
but I don't know what to do.
But that's pretty much it you know.
Times is hard. A lot of gangs.
I got into a couple of fights out here.
Cops are arse holes out here, they, they,
they judge you. You know,
based on our living environment and stuff.
And it's just, it's not
the place to be, you know.
And I just, I wish, I
wish I could, you know,
I wish I knew what to do,
I wish I had some guidance
in my life, to show
me, you know to show me
how to get out of this situation.
And it's very expensive to
live out here in LA too.
Very expensive. Preposterously expensive.
- [Mark] What's the
difference mainly between
crystal meth and heroin?
- Crystal I brought along. Crystal,
I use them both at the
same time, actually.
I shoot up, you know.
And I shoot them both up at the same time.
Crystal meth is an upper,
heroin is a downer.
You know. You feel tired
and numb on heroin.
Crystal you feel alive and
you want to do more things,
you're more motivated to do things.
You know. And crystal gets
you horny too, you know.
It makes you feeling good and you're more,
yeah, you're more, you know,
kinda raises your sexual
stimulus, you know.
That's pretty much it, you know.
One's an upper, one's a downer.
I do ectasy too. You know,
pretty much everything.
Well, psychedelics too. And M.
- [Mark] Do you think there's any chance
of you getting clean on your own?
- No, I'm too far down, unless
I go to jail or something.
- [Mark] Jail's a good
way of getting clean
for a lot of people, who just don't
have the ability to do it on their own.
- Yeah. I don't see it. I'm
too far down my addiction,
you know. I don't see myself quitting,
I see myself using till the
day I die, unfortunately.
You know. And I, I just, you know.
I'm thankful I'm still
somewhat coherent, you know.
And you know, I used to
have all my teeth still.
I lost a lot of teeth. And it
looks like I may have teeth,
but I lost all my back
teeth are pretty much gone.
I haven't honestly showered
in a week and a half.
You know. It's just, you know.
Everyday is like limbo, you know.
I'm reliving the same
day over and over again.
You know. I thought it was January,
I thought it was before January
10th, but it's the 17th.
It's crazy how days just fly past you.
I feel like my life is being wasted.
I feel like there's so
many days are passing by
that could do productively
and I'm just, I'm just,
It's just going right past me. You know.
And it fucking pisses me off man.
And I had to deal with this
fucking drama and stuff.
And I'm so new out here too
and I don't really know what
you know, I'm not really familiar
with, you know, fuck man.
- [Mark] How long have you been in the US?
- I've been in the, I'll
tell you, about, about,
six years, you know.
- [Mark] Six years.
- I've been, I've been out here
for three years, but in
the US for six years.
I was living with a
gentleman with some modeling
for three years, I was
doing that out there.
You know. So, but yeah
man, it's not the busi...
And there's a lot of, a lot of,
a lot of gay people out here, you know.
A lot of them are fucking gay, you know.
And a lot of people would
think that I'm, I'm into that,
since I've done that, you know.
And I get, you don't understand,
I get people coming into my
tent in the middle of the night,
you know. I've got people
trying to trick me, you know.
Into, Oh yeah I've got some
crystal, come over here
you know, to get in their tent, you know.
And they pull their
pants down and whip it,
you know, whip out their... you know.
And it's just very uncomfortable for me.
But I mean my addiction and I and
it's fucked up.
So I'm trying to find
somewhere else to go.
You know, so I don't have
to deal with this, but
I can't help but laugh, there's
some fucked up shit man.
You know, I'm just, you know,
I even contemplated suicide
a couple of times, you know.
I know it could always be
worse, I understand that,
you know. But I just feel like I'm just,
I OD'd four or five times
being out here, you know.
You know I'm using fentanyl now, you know.
I've upgraded from heroin to fentanyl.
Are you familiar with fentanyl?
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Dangerous.
- Yeah, so I'm, yeah, I
nearly died twice off that.
You know. Yeah.
You know and crystal
doesn't really do anything,
you know I shoot up a whole
dime in one shot, you know.
And it's not even good crystal,
a lot of it's cut, you know.
So I don't know what the fuck is in that.
I haven't got any abscesses, thank god.
You know.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I am 28.
- [Mark] 28.
- 27, I apologize, 27. Yes.
- [Mark] Wow.
Well, Damien, I wish you luck
in terms of getting some help.
- Some guidance, hopefully.
You know, opportunity falls into my lap.
You know, and I'm like,
Because I'm just waiting.
But the whole earth
thing is going to end up
to anything I want to do
that's productive and positive.
- [Mark] Right. Getting a job?
- Exactly. It's always going to interfere.
You know, so hopefully
something happens in my life
where I can put the drugs behind me
and go through the witch
halls and move forward.
But I don't see that happening, honestly.
That's why it keeps me
happy, honestly, you know.
It's the only way I'm content.
God, I'm content with my life and happy
because of drugs, you know.
It's awful, you know.
Yeah man, thank you and you know.
I don't, you know, at the
end I know this is going up,
you know I don't really
share these experiences
with anyone. I think you're
the third person I've told.
Actually, you know.
Even about my father, so, you know.
And it feels good to talk about it, man.
I appreciate your time and I
appreciate you listening man.
- [Mark] Keeping it hidden,
sometimes gives it more power.
- No, of course, you know, it does.
It eats at you, you know,
psychologically speaking.
It eats at you and you
become more depressed.
And you become, it's just,
it's awful, you know.
So I'm just glad that I'm
able to talk about this
and thank you for your time, you know.
You know, did you have
any other questions?
- [Mark] No. I hear your
story and it's heartbreaking
and I wish something could happen for you.
Sometimes it's just
jail, sometimes it's just
getting thrown into
prison, jail, whatever.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That forces you to get clean
and then somehow, you
seem sensible enough.
You might actually break
free and stay clean.
- I never really been in
jail before, so you know.
I'm not really, well yeah,
if it happens, it happens,
you know, whatever.
You know, I mean if it happens that way,
it happens that way, you know.
And I hear a lot of people
going to jail on purpose,
you know, just to get, fuck that.
At night it's fucking cold too.
Jesus Christ, man. Fuck man.
It's fucking cold man.
You don't understand.
And Oh god, I need to get some blankets.
Man that sounds fucked dood.
And we still do shit bro
out here, blankets, bugs.
You won't even believe dood.
- [Mark] It's horrible
here, it's just horrible.
This is the worst place
I've ever seen in the US.
- You know what I'm saying?
And people are just fucking crazy man.
Fuck.
It's cold but, yeah, so...
Yeah man, but you know, I've
been out here this long.
You know, people usually going through
what I'm going through are
usually kind of psychologically
f-ed up in the head, you know.
They usually have some,
they usually, kind of
I don't know, I don't know.
But I'm glad, I, to you,
I feel like I'm coherent
and I feel like that I'm like all there
mentally speaking and I've got a grasp
on who I am and I haven't
lost myself yet, you know.
For the most part, you know.
And yeah, I could tell
that crystal was taking,
you know, taking effect
on me on a negative way.
I found myself taking to myself.
I found myself doing things
that I wouldn't normally
do on a daily basis.
You know. Like, like, you know, like
for instance like my
tongue, like doing that.
I do that a lot. I
would talk to myself and
catch myself talking to myself.
And I do a lot of admirable things that I,
I don't see my, you know, it's just,
I can see how I can
really fuck with people.
You know. And I'm shooting, I just,
but then again, I don't
see myself stopping man.
No. And I died, I died
like a couple of times.
I think three or four times, I told you.
Something like that, over
three times I've died.
Ambulance, the ambulance had to come
and bring me back to life, you know.
Yeah, dood. It's crazy, you think somebody
who would go through all
that would stop, you know.
But I'm right here.
- [Mark] Yeah. No, it's not
about a rational decision
it's about having the strength somehow
to steer clear of that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Which is a lot, right? It's hard.
- I believe that everybody
needs deep, like you know.
It's crazy like somebody
dies off of a heroin
off a heroin dies, they
want to go to the guy who,
who sold him that bag.
Because that's the good stuff.
You know, isn't that, isn't that insane?
You know, but.
But I'm that guy going to get high,
you know what I'm saying?
It's fucked up out here and man
it's not cool, it's not
the way to live though.
I could tell you right now, you know,
it is not, I feel like
this is, I feel like,
I'm happy and content,
but I absolutely know
this is not the correct
way, well this is not normal
in any sense of the manner, you know.
And I know that, I understand that
but somehow I still trip myself in that,
you know, you know.
It's crazy I could go out here and maybe
this is normal to me, you know.
Outsiders would come and
be, like what the hell,
where am I? This is home
to me in a sense, no?
And a lot of bad stuff has happened to me,
but a lot of good stuff
has happened to me too.
A lot of acceptance, a lot of good people
that I came across, you know.
A lot of good, genuine
people are out here too,
you know. But, you know.
Also, you know, anywhere you
going, there's going to be bad.
But out here, it's a
trip though. You know.
You hear the stories all
day, but like you know.
Man, there, there, yeah.
It's just, it's crazy.
Honestly, I wish I could
have stayed in Greece.
But if I could go back
in time to tell my, my,
you know, my younger self,
to not make that decision.
You know the shit I was having
with my father back in Greece
this is not worth it at all. You know.
I've got nowhere to go to.
I haven't got my family or anyone.
You know I came out here
by myself, you know.
I got nowhere to go to
family wise, you know.
And I can't call them
and tell them, because I,
I cry every time I talk. Last time I
talked to mom, was honest,
a year and a half ago.
And I told her all these
lies and I'm crying
as I'm telling her all these lies cause
that's it, you know and
that's why I imagine,
it's crazy, you're talking
to your family member
and my mom telling you how
life, how I expected it to be
but beside me is like a rat, you know,
trying to get in my tent, you know.
And it's just, it's sad the
way that things have turned.
And I thank god I've got my girlfriend,
she's an amazing support of me, you know.
But then again, you know, but then again
I feel like I'm the reason she's down here
you know. She has a kid, she
needs to go be with her kid.
Be with her family.
She doesn't need to be out here with me.
You know I'm the one
bringing her down, you know.
And I don't need that, you know.
No, it's just fucked up man.
- [Mark] Thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- No problem brother. And
thank you for your time.
- [Mark] And good luck with everything.
- All right man.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Damien] Thank you.